so sex and sushi $30,000 film you made
it once you left Wall Street you felt
like it was a great experience for you
you did another film and I believe it
was called crave right okay I didn't do
it I wrote it you wrote it you know
someone else directed it correct okay
how did all that happen cuz you have a
successful show so I 6x knew she wasn't
a great success but it got me noticed
and somebody it got me noticed by this
guy who was a producer who wanted to
direct his first feature and he said I
like that what else do you have
so I I said I have this idea it's I just
sort of pitched him an idea I had and he
said I like that go write that so I did
and we're a couple drafts of it and we
sort of didn't see eye to eye and he's
eventually said I just want to buy the
script from you and rewrite it and go
make the movie and it was an amicable
and he that's what he did and I still
haven't seen the movie to tell you the
truth but they made the movie and the
trailer looks awesome by the way yeah I
like cool yeah right oh my god bless him
he's a talented guy the guy who made the
movie rewrote it he's a very talented
guy and visually but I I didn't I read
the shooting drafts and I it wasn't for
me and I remember I was having lunch
with these two great guys charlie Brill
and Jack burns in right not far from
here and I was complaining I said I am
miserable I sold this script and they
changed the title they're adding
characters there I was lamenting what
was going on and I was really unhappy I
was thinking about taking my name off of
it and so forth yep and Charlie said to
me you're a pro screenwriter now you
need to learn this sentence and just say
it all the time
sounds good to me so if the studio says
we want to take your lead actor and make
it a 12 year old Eskimo girl sounds good
to me and that was good advice I need
to hear that a B another friend of mine
said to me um you sold a script you know
so you should really be happy about it
they're making it so just you know shut
up be happy most people don't yeah that
was good advice so how important was
that for you to hear that at that time
and how have you carried that with you
that's something that you still say
would do rain yourself back in when like
you start getting too close to the
material and somebody wants to change
something it depends I mean if
somebody's writing a check and they're
paying me like sounds good to me that's
easy but if it's a spec script and
somebody wants to rewrite it and stuff
like that I'm very typically I'm like
yeah I'll consider it if it's a good
idea I'll do it but I'm all business on
my own stuff and I'm all business in a
different way on your if you're paying
me to do something whatever you want I'm
here to serve you yeah so your advice
too I mean I understand a younger
screenwriter or somebody just right out
the gate that's like oh but I've written
this and this is so amazing and they
can't change this character and this and
that and aside from the sounds good to
me which is a perfect phrase how do you
teach them to let go of all that that's
a good problem to have you know that's
what I had to learn like keep it in
perspective people would kill to have
that problem so you know if somebody's
paying you they own it it's their
material now I'm sure you're beholding
to it in a certain way and you know you
have to stick to your guns but you know
if it comes down to your vision or
theirs you're gonna lose and you should
you